a hunter is a hunter even in a dream
though you may not have many dreams left
if you're waiting for the old hunters
DLC to launch I'm Dave and welcome to
your gamespot news update with the
blood-bond expansion the old hunters
just on the horizon producer Misaki yeah
McGee were has shared new details in a
post on the PlayStation Blog first he
talked about some of the menacing new
enemies your face which include an
ancient hunter named brad or and a
hulking faux called the bell holder Brad
I was an ancient hunter and assassin
once employed by the healing church who
sits in a dark cell waiting for
something or someone with bell in hand
yeah McGee were said and whilst
exploring the new nightmare beware of
the Bell holder this massive enemy
wheels the bell axe and is one of the
most formidable beasts you will face as
the new weapons coming to blood-borne
through the old hunters the first of
these is called the blood letter it's
described as a sick and demented weapon
the Brad or wields this weapon assumes
its true form after drawing upon the
blood of its wielder in other words you
must plunge into your own chest in order
to unleash its true power yeah McGee
were also provided step-by-step
instructions how to access the old
hunters content inside of blood-borne
step 1 defeat the boss the cathedral
ward and examine the altar in the back
of the room to change the ingame time
tonight step 2 go to the hunter's dream
and receive the eye of a blood drunk
hunter from a messenger step 3 go to the
oedon chapel and leave you the left hand
exit to enter the square step 4 go to
the right hand end of the square to
trigger event this event will take you
to the new area the hunters nightmare
lighting the lamp in the new area will
allow you to travel to and from the area
via an awakening headstone in the
hunter's dream the old hunters tell the
story of the legendary hunters
referenced in the main game and is set
in a nightmare world where hunters from
the past trapped forever sony shuhei
yoshida described blood-borne the old
hunters as a full-scale download so will
you rejoin the front when the old
hunters launched on the 24th november or
is there a boss you're still struggling
to be let us know in the comments
section below or you can find me on
twitter at a regular dave and for all
your news and hunt updates for
blood-borne keep an eye on gamespot com